Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the opening verses of Surah Musl
is
either 19 or 20 verses.
Now a person may ask 19 or 20. How does
that work?
This is an important point for us to
contemplate
and that is that
the way that the verses are numbered
mostly
is based on
how the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
used to recite the Quran to the
companions. and most of it is agreed
upon.
However, distinguishing which verse ends
where
and which verse begins
where,
this is an issue that is not completely
agreed upon amongst the scholars of
the scholars of the Quran.
So
we don't have a problem with our book
problems that plague the other books
because their scholarship
was not trustworthy.
You look at the Torah that was given to
Misam the
given to
the Zab that was given to Benu. They did
not follow through with their
entrustment.
Benu Israel's scholars
were
no not much better and no better largely
than the rest of the ignorant among them
amongst them
and as a result
they dropped the ball with their book.
Some of them deliberately altered it,
but general
general
lack of passion and dutifulness is what
plagued their books. So you see now that
after all these hundreds of years
that these books are not agreed upon
not just the number of verses but the
number of books themselves
we don't have versions of the Quran we
have one Quran
there are versions of understanding that
one Quran
but even that has been preserved by
Allah Subhanahu wa ta'ala. But we don't
have printed multiple versions of the
Quran.
There is one Quran. It has 114 chapters
in it. And every single letter of that
book is exactly how it was when it was
revealed to our prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam 1500 years ago.
But the previous books,
the Torah, the Injil, the Zabur,
they were not protected and preserved by
their scholars.
And
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala blames them
largely in the Quran for their lack of
dutifulness
in preserving those books. So now you
have versions of the Bible,
versions where some they have extra
books in it, entire books,
up to 15 or even 20 books difference
between the different versions. more
than 40 versions of the Bible which is
an amalgamation
of parts of the Tawra parts of the Zabur
and parts of Aljid which is what we have
today called the modern Bible we don't
have this issue in the Quran in the
Quran every letter is agreed upon
amongst the scholars however
the exact numbers of verses
where this verse ends and where this one
begins. That's an issue that has been
differed upon. So the actual text itself
is not differed upon. However,
the division of that text into verses
there is a difference in the chains of
narration and in the ite.
So for instance, we'll take a good
example of this is
at the beginning of fat a verse of fat
or is it not a verse? And if it's a a
verse
is the last verse
is that one verse or is that part of the
last verse? This is an issue differed
upon.
This is what's called as the science of
counting and determining the verses of
the Quran.
Is this all one verse or is one verse
and
the second verse etc. The differences
are in this way.
And so we know for certain if is part of
the Quran
is part of the Quran. But is it all part
of the same verse or is that two verses
is part of the Quran? But is it the
first verse of Fat or is it an
independent verse on its own or is it
just something that is a marking? And so
the companions,
they did not worry themselves with
numbers.
They wrote the Quran and they all agreed
in those original mah that they
distributed in the time of man not to
include a single pen stroke
that is not part of the Quran.
Not a single pen stroke that is not part
of the words of Allah. And so everything
in those mah is is part of the Quran.
How we divide it up that is an issue
that is is differed upon. But even that
differing is very very slight. You won't
find a scholar that says this chapter is
20 verses and another who says this is
actually 50 verses. It's not that
dramatic.
It is merely an issue of where one
sentence ends and where the next begins
and picks up because as we know there is
no punctuation
in the Arabic language as it originally
was punctuation period commas
exclamation po point or mark
question mark colons semicolons etc.
these things. This is punctuation. This
is for English, not in Arabic. Arabic
the the language of the actual words
themselves carry their punctuation. It's
unnecessary. It's redundant and it's
unneeded. And so this is why there would
be a difference. But it doesn't mean
that there is a difference in the actual
words of the Quran or in the actual
verses. But now this brings us to a very
interesting issue. If we understand
that the numbers of verses and where one
starts and the other ends is something
which there is an issue an element of it
had an element of opinion to it and it
is something that is not agreed upon
amongst the scholars nor is it agreed
upon with respect to the chains of
narration.
This now brings into question
the whole numerical
quote unquote numerical miracles
of the Quran,
right? You read some books or some
interesting fun facts about the Quran.
They say look at this verse number in
this chapter in this place. It says this
and you look at for instance and
everyone wants to find their numbers
and think that it's there's some kind of
connection there. Entire books have been
written on this and it's very fun to
imagine. We can understand the allure,
the attraction people have to it.
However, this is not a science of Islam.
This never was a science of Islam. This
was never something that was
that was
you know something that was written
on or explored in the time of the major
scholars of this and the this is
something that when was it introduced?
It was largely introduced in the last
hundred years or so. And it was largely
introduced because of people's obsession
with numbers in this new materialistic
way of seeing the world. And it was
largely introduced because the Muslim
started to overlook the point of the
Quran and start to look at the aspects
of it that were not intended to be
looked at in that way. is when Allah
would say to them
something like
threw down his staff and it turned into
a snake. Benu is would say, "What kind
of snake? What kind of stick was it?
What was the wood made out of? What was
he wearing when he did that? Did the
snake could it bite someone? What how
how long was it? How tall was it?" No.
am built the ark and then when Allah
opened the gates of the heavens and the
earth and all of this waves of water
came in to destroy people instead of
them thinking of that they say well how
big was the ark exactly did it have
windows in it how big were those windows
this is how benel used to think why
because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us that many of them largely took their
religion as a source of entertainment.
It was something to entertain them and
we need those details in order to be
entertained. And that is why when you
read in the modern Bible today, what do
you read? The most dry
details on things, right? There were
fish. How many fish exactly did he
catch? And what type of fish were they?
And what they said and what he said and
what he said back. Why? Because they
asked their prophets all of these
unnecessary questions and their prophets
could not withhold knowledge from them.
So every time they asked something like
this, they would get a response. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala taught our
companions
not to do that. our ancestors. He said,
[Silence]
"So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said to
the companions, "Do not ask about things
that if they were shown to you, they
would end up being bad for you.
But if you insist on asking anyways,
they will be to told to you. You will
receive the answers to those questions.
And some men even in the time of the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
came and asked him questions men
ebbi who's my real father because they
didn't know who their father was my real
father what came out because of these
questions
entire family structures fell apart
because of the answers to these
questions
and so the prophet sallallahu alaii
wasallam received this verse and the
companions would not ask about anything
unless it was absolely absolutely
critical to upholding a an already
established command or prohibition.
This is how our companions were. And
that is why the Quran is concise and
dense in its knowledge. Every letter has
benefit to us and is of consequence.
There's no fluff there. Why is there no
fluff? Because largely because of how
great our ancestors were, our self, the
companions of our prophet sallall.aii
wasallam,
how they were. And this is why when they
ask about something,
we follow their lead and ask and
research it. And when they would not ask
about something, we leave that door. We
don't ask about it because they were
more
they were far more passionate about
this religion than we will ever be. And
they did not leave a single stone
unturned. Not a single curtain unopened.
not a single door that they didn't knock
on if it was something that would be of
consequence for them or their their
lineage or the Muslim that would come
after them. So a lot of these and this
is why and we'll end with this point.
Do you notice that
this kind of phenomenon that came out in
the last say hundred years or so about
the quote unquote alleged scientific
miracles of the Quran or the numerical
miracles of the Quran etc. There is
you know the religion of Allah is always
in the middle between the two extremes.
There are groups that say no, there are
no scientific or numerical miracles in
the Quran at all. That is incorrect.
And then there are those who all they
see when they hear the Quran or read it
is as if the the Quran is a book on
geography, as if the Quran is a book a
book on metallurgy or a book on physics
or a book on space exploration. That is
not the point of the Quran. And that is
not what it was revealed for. It may
have elements of that in it, but those
are never the center thrust of the
Quran. The Quran is our technology to
establish a relationship with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. It is an
instruction manual. It is a map to guide
us to Allah's pleasure and away from his
hellfire.
And so
are there some numerical
some striking numerical elements of
the Quran? Sure. Right. The word day and
night are mentioned 360 times each in
the Quran. Is that amazing? Very
amazing. Incredible. Right. the word
devil and and and angel are mentioned an
equal amount of times throughout the
Quran. Amazing. Incredible. Are those
intentional? Everything in the Quran is
intentional.
But is 911 mentioned in the Quran?
Did Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala place that
little bread breadcrumb in there for us
to learn about Bush and Cheney and the
What is this? This is not a people who
take their book seriously who treat it
in this way. Is the Quran talking about
when we're going to go to space? how we
got to go to space. Well, the Quran
didn't come to teach us how to go to
space.
And so there may be elements of this
mentioned, but it is mentioned in
passing and it is never the center
thrust. And it is something that cannot
be reached
for. It's not something that we're
supposed to twist the Quran in order to
make it mean that. It's something that
makes itself apparent
if you were to look at whether the earth
is flat or round in the Quran. You know
what's interesting about that? The same
evidences used to prove that it is round
are the exact same evidences used by
earlier scholars to prove that it is
flat. Exact same evidences. Why is that?
Because that doesn't matter to our
relationship with Allah. If the earth is
round or flat or or or discshaped or a
triangle, it doesn't make any difference
with respect to our relationship with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
It is not definitive for a purpose. And
for this reason, you'll find that the
people that most obsess
about
these elements of the Quran often times
are most weak in their upholding of the
prophet's sunnah sallall.aii wasallam.
You will find very few
signs of the sunnah on their po person
and in their lives.
They are very usually often rather
ignorant with regards to
the
meanings of the Quran and Sunnah
that the Quran and Sunnah were intended
for.
Why? because their focus is not on what
the Quran was revealed for. They are
focusing on what the same thing Benel
was focused on before. What type of wood
was the staff made of and what type of
snake did it become? And exactly what
color use of clothing was that the
blood was put on and what type of blood
was it? And when Adam and How ate from
the tree, what type of tree was it? And
they completely missed the point of the
actual story and metaphors or or
parables that the Quran holds. There is
nothing on this earth that has ever been
here of knowledge that is grander or
greater than the Quran. Ever. Ever.
This is the pinnacle
of human potential.
However, a shaitan will try to always
stop a person on their path. And if he
can do that by making a person
hyperfocus
on the wrong things, then that is a
method that he will use to great extent.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]